bonsoir messieurs on l'a vu hier vous
arrivez grand patron Diderot Québec et
on l'a vu hier à quel point le réseau et
peut être la victime de feu de forêt
également et vulnérable on a connu le
verglas plusieurs reprises on le sait
les feux aussi ce réseau là on doit le
solidifier
contenu des changements climatiques
changements climatique qui explique
les pannes je suis bien content de vous
dire que l'équipe il est au Québec a
déjà réglé dépanne mais quand même ce
phénomène du changement climatique des
feux de forêt des verbes ça représente
non ça c'est que ça c'est clair donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
comme un point de départ il faut
investir pour continuer à renforcer
la résilience du réseau il faut
continuer d'augmenter
nos pratiques de maintenance pour
essayer de réduire des instances des
pannes parce que le changement
climatique c'est quelque chose qui est
avec nous maintenant à long terme et
donc ils font nous préparer
mais selon moi c'est une chose une
priorité importante en attendant
d'autres de la priorité parce que le
changement climatique c'est une autre
c'est une autre façon de parler de cette
transformation énergétique qui est
fondamentalement importante et qui amène
des besoins en électricité en
hydroélectricité qu'on avait pas
soupçonné il y a même quelques années
monsieur Martel qui a occupé votre poste
disait il y aura des surplus on nage
dans les surplus on sait pas quoi faire
il faut pas produire plus même sophie
Brochu il y a un an et demi déjà faut
pas avoir le syndrome du castor avec des
barrages il faut il faut rationaliser ce
qu'on a avant de penser à d'autres
choses là on est dans une autre aire là
vous acceptez cette hypothèse cette idée
que les besoins vont exploser
tout à fait
la période
la période pendant laquelle électricité
est abondante cette période est derrière
nous maintenant c'est fini c'est surplus
c'est fini c'est fini et de plus en plus
maintenant électricité
sobre en carbone propre
c'est une chose précieuse
et donc ce n'est pas comme tu disais ce
n'est plus abondant mais c'est précieux
et il faut traiter cette électricité
comme un actif précieux qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire donc
si je peux vous donner une comparaison
pendant le 20e siècle le pétrole a
propulsé le processus de développement
économique 21e siècle c'est électricité
propre qui va propulser le processus de
développement économique donc pour nous
ici au Québec il faut faire des
investissements nécessaires pour
augmenter l'offre pour améliorer le
bilan entre la demande et l'offre pour
avoir
l'électricité propre qui est nécessaire
pour naviguer cette transition et donc à
la fois bâtir un économique québécoise
prospère et à la fois comme je disais
sobre en cabane ça c'est l'essentiel du
défi et évidemment c'est une grande
grande et ça suppose donc et en ça vous
êtes d'accord avec votre actionnaire le
seul le gouvernement vous êtes d'accord
qu'il faut accélérer la production
d'électricité il faut faire plusieurs
choses
donc idéal avec
le mot bilan il y a deux côtés on a un
côté de monde à une côté offre il faut
travailler sur les deux donc il faut
trouver des façons des moyennes de
consommer mieux
les sociétés mais également les ménages
les deux ensemble ça c'est un côté un
élément du problème et je pense qu'il
faut investir pour réaliser cet objectif
et également oui il faut investir pour
augmenter l'offre parce que il faut
faire les deux ensemble et ça c'est la
seule façon de donner le bilan de
iro-québec
une marge de manœuvre parce qu'on a et
on a vu avec Madame Brochu avec le
gouvernement des tensions quand elle
parlait de dollars elle donnait
l'impression que Monsieur faitgaben et
d'autres voulaient accélérer la venue de
gros joueurs très énergivore au Québec
pour faire rouler l'économie qu'il
fallait pas nécessairement vendre à ces
gens-là ces joueurs là l'électricité à
bas prix il fallait pas développer à
tout prix pour ça il y avait une
différence de vision peu importe vous
vous épousez la vision de Monsieur felda
et monsieur Legault vous avez discuté de
ces choses là vous êtes en accord avec
votre vos actionnaires moi je dirais oui
évidemment nous avons échangé sur des
défis sur des occasions des opportunités
ça c'est évident
ceci dit
comme je disais électricité fait partie
essentiaire c'est une instrument de
développement économique
fondamentalement importante pour
l'avenir du Québec pour bâtir une
économie prospère et la prospérité
touche tout le monde donc évidemment
c'est une priorité hautement importante
ceci dit comme je disais électricité de
plus en plus maintenant un actif
précieux donc ce n'est pas juste une
question de vendre à Rebais le prix
d'électricité il faut trouver un
équilibre entre pour respecter oui c'est
précieux mais également c'est
fondamental pour contribuer au
développement économique du Québec
nouveau barrage ce que c'est inévitable
est-ce que c'est ça sera dans le jeu des
possibilités quelque chose où on devra
aller
selon moi et pas on est juste au début
donc mais selon moi étant donné nos
circonstances étant donné le fait simple
que cette période d'abondance et
derrière nous maintenant il faut garder
un esprit ouvert il faut regarder
l'ensemble des options pour améliorer
l'offre est-ce que le meilleur solution
se débarrasse ou d'autres options pour
l'instant je ne sais pas mais mon
engagement est de garder notre prix
ouverte examiner toutes les options et
d'essayer de mettre ensemble une plan
pour comme je disais naviguer cette
transition énergétique fondamentalement
importante le privé il y a déjà des
petits barrages privés au Québec il y a
des gens des joueurs privés dans
l'éolien et privé est-ce que vous vous
êtes d'accord est-ce que on explore
encore plus cette voix du privé
selon moi juste pour dire une chose pour
répondre à la question que vous n'avez
pas posée
c'est suivant est-ce que personnellement
j'envisage la privatisation des
Hydro-Québec ma réponse est non
mais
un contexte politique
de plus en plus petit ça c'est
depuis longtemps depuis des décennies le
privé est présent dans la protection
d'électricité au Québec donc selon moi
c'est un élément de continuité mais ça
soulève un autre question intéressant
des partenariats parce que
étant donné notre circonstances et
statistique autre élément de l'idée de
garder nos esprits ouverts est-ce que
nous sommes est-ce que nous sommes en
mesure de trouver des occasions de
travailler en partenariat soit avec le
privé soit avec
par exemple le nord-est des États-Unis
avec des connexions que nous avons
maintenant entre le Québec et le
nord-est des États-Unis donc il y a
plein de choses il y a plein d'occasions
mais il faut explorer l'ensemble de ces
occasions le cinquième de l'électricité
que les Québécois consomme arrive de
Terre-Neuve comme vous savez très bien
vous serez un joueur clé dans la
négociation avec Terre-Neuve vous
connaissez bien le dossier vous
connaissez bien aussi l'autre dossier
est-ce que d'abord sous question le
fédéral va financer il va aller de
l'avant avec la boucle Atlantique parce
que Terre-Neuve veut vendre aussi aux
autres provinces atlantiques sans passer
par le Québec cette boucle là ce que
vous y croyez donc le de la seule chose
que je vais vous dire sur toujours fort
évidemment c'est une projet important
très importante
et les gouttes travaillent travaillent
entre le Québec et la Terre Neuve
évidemment je vais suivre ce dossier de
prêt parce qu'évidemment cette élément
important notre exemple garder nos
esprits ouverts ceci dit ce n'est pas
évidemment une solution magique parce
que ça va ça va prendre du temps mais
quand même ça reste oui une priorité
importante et oui un de mes priorités je
vous recommençais l'entrevue en vous
parlant des feuillères il y a eu donc
gestion de crise là il y a eu 300 000
Québécois qui n'ont pas eu d'électricité
le travail de grand patron
d'Hydro-Québec c'est aussi
j'allais dire de mettre un col roulé on
fait référence au verglas à l'époque le
dirigeant mais c'est d'aller vers le
monde c'est de faire des conférences de
presse est-ce que ça vous serez à l'aise
avec
l'interconnexion si je peux dire avec le
public
laissez-moi vous dire je pense un des
choses
Sophie a fait beaucoup de bonnes choses
beaucoup de bonnes choses je connais
Sophie depuis des années
une chose qu'elle a fait et je pense de
te la bonne façon elle a renforcé les
liens entre hiro-québec et les Québécois
les Québécoises et je pense que
maintenant une PDG de Hydro-Québec il
faut accepter cette responsabilité parce
que en fin du compte hiro-québec est un
entreprises de service service aux
sociétés
et donc service à la clientèle cette un
élément important c'est primordial et
c'est important à vos yeux
c'est fondamental et donc comme tu
disais quand j'étais à la caisse il est
important que les Québécois a respecté
la confiance envers la caisse c'est la
même chose et même peut-être de façon
feu direct Hydro-Québec deux trois
petites questions rapides rapides puis
je vous laisse aller après
je vous mets à l'épreuve des tarifs
différenciés selon l'heure pour
justement rendre les Québécois peut-être
plus responsable pour la consommation
c'est peut-être oui non il faut garder
un esprit ouvert examiner les options
est-ce qu'il y a une façon de le faire
que les gens vont accepter il faut
examiner ça nucléaire
j'ai une option encore une fois garder
un esprit ouvert parce que étant donné
l'importance de augmenter l'offre il
faut examiner toutes les options
l'ensemble des options troisième et
dernière question Raphaël si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec Monsieur fitzguiben
monsieur Legault vous allez dire non
parce que vous n'êtes pas connu comme
yES man là vous êtes plutôt connu comme
vous avez beaucoup de caractère
ça va bien aller oui je pense que le
gouvernement me connaît
et donc parce que j'étais à la caisse du
travail avec avec ce gouvernement pierre
n'était membre du conseil
d'administration pour une période de
temps quand j'étais à la caisse donc je
pense que le gouvernement comprendre le
produit qu'ils achètent et donc je pense
que les commandes ce n'est pas la
meilleure façon de travailler avec moi
vous êtes là pour combien de temps parce
que Madame brochet avait un contrat de 5
ans les parties vous êtes là pour
combien de temps
puis pour vrai pour vrai très bien
on va se reparler merci beaucoup merci à
vous